were saying a lot in the comments
because you were like oh because you
know because you're intimidated by me
and i'm just like no i'm definitely not
intimidated by you
but do you feel like like it's like you
felt like people are intimidated by you
um it's not that i feel that way it's
that a lot of people have said so
a lot of people have approached me like
like people who like may not have been
my friend yet you know like if i first
meet them they'll be like i was honestly
very intimidated by you i think like
your demeanor comes off like very strong
you know that doesn't necessarily mean
it's a bad thing it's not like i give
like negative aura or something like
that i'm not walking around like angry
[ __ ] face all the time but i know that
my energy is a little bit different for
most people but then people get to know
me and they're like oh my god you're so
much nicer than i thought like you're so
sweet this and that and i'm like yeah i
mean i don't have to be super nice to
everybody right away you know i don't
know you
we gotta like form a friendship here
before i start you know treating you
like one of my close friends so
yeah
i also think it like
i think there's a difference between
like maybe the us and the uk
when it comes to like the way people
interact
yes we're louder yeah you guys are like
louder and more like we're more enthus
enthusiastic though
like like
me and gabby have been in situations
where like telling a story to like like
british people right and we just get so
into it we'll be like yeah
yeah and like the british people in the
room will be like what is wrong with
these girls there were a couple times
where like you know people would be like
get to the point of the story and i'm
like no but you have to hear this like
you have to know what i'm about to talk
about you have to know the whole thing
you have to know the whole story whole
story i have to be like mind you on this
day at this time this happened like you
know like i realize people are very like
short straight and to the point but i
feel like that kind of loses the fun
interaction behind like social
interaction you know like that kind of
loses its
genuineness behind it like i feel like
we don't have to rush conversation we
can have fun and like talk about things
in detail because that
that's what makes it fun like i'm a
storyteller like i sure as hell i'm a
storyteller so if you ask me a question
i probably will give you a story behind
it
so so question um i'm not sure because
you kind of you say a lot of things that
are very much like feminists like
feminists say them but at the same time
you're not sure if you're you identify
as a feminist right yeah the reason why
i have difficulty
pegging myself as a feminist is
i feel like it
i think society's viewpoint of feminism
is extreme okay you know because
oftentimes when we see feminists it's
the more extreme side of it right like
we could say the same thing for certain
religions races whatever it may be so in
this case like the social construct of
feminism and equality or equity
like people tend to look at it in a
negative way and i'm very much an equal
rights equal less person you know like
if i see a woman is [ __ ] up i will
call it out like it is like i i fully
believe in that because i feel like a
lot of people do let women get away with
bs that doesn't need to be happening
okay so i think that's the reason why i
don't really come off as a feminist per
se i think i just really believe in
what kind of bs do you think that women
get away with
sometimes abusing men i feel like that's
like the most basic thing that i could
come up with now
um
because like i said briefly in the last
uh time that i was here like my mom was
abusing my dad straight up but my dad
couldn't really do much about it you
know because like
everyone's thinking like oh this poor
woman
she must be getting abused by her man so
she has to fight back or something like
nah it's not it's really not like that
it's really my mom being abusive and
people would be very quick to take a
woman's side in a case where she very
well might be wrong like the johnny depp
case right now yeah that is a freaking
mess like we need to hold this woman
accountable she is a menace to society
so what like what points do you agree
with feminism on
like what where do you think um like
what are we missing in 2020 don't you
think like because feminism like came in
waves didn't it she had first wave
second wave third wave feminism so
i think it's kind of difficult to answer
that because i need like a an example
right so that i can say like yeah i
agree or no i don't and this is why
because like first wave feminism i agree
with okay personally
women want equality you want equal pay
you know um you want to be treated just
as a man's treated i'm down with that i
think the the waves after that it got
progressively and progressively worse in
my personal point of view like it for me
feminism became
not so much equality but now about
revenge
and
i said on my show the other day right
that
feminism this newer form of feminism has
given women the power
to be
just like the most heinous man or the
most heinous men in history
right you know the abusers the sexual
abusers the people that used to talk to
people derogatory but giving them the
the get out of not having accountability
for doing it
that's what i believe feminism today has
done i believe it's you can say you know
what [ __ ] men they're this they're trash
and there's no accountability on your
side but see i feel like that's not true
feminism then i think that's just being
a misandrist
at the end of the day like
that's something that's not spoken about
enough though miss andre is not spoken
about enough oh i agree i think that's
like 90 percent of feminists today if
i'm being honest like
when i talk to most feminists they have
a slight disdain for men
like even if i say oh we need men in
society like we argue
well i believe in that because we need a
balance at the end of the day we we're
going to need both men and women at the
end of the day if we're going to
function properly because there's some
things that men can do and some things
that women can do that the other
gender sex cannot provide you need men
to build stuff
if you're honest yeah no i mean they
mean like a shelf
no like they're like what do you mean
like like are we talking about like
building the shop from ikea no like the
mic that you're using right now
this stuff yeah like they run the
infrastructure of society like most if
men disappeared today society would
collapse if women disappeared it
wouldn't
outside of reproductive reasons yeah i
can agree with that
but i always bring it back to the
foundation of what like these countries
and infrastructure has been built on
right so like which is when we look at
like stem majors for example a lot of
engineering all that kind of stuff uh
it's not woman dominated whatsoever you
know like
i don't know what the statistics are
exactly but i i can guarantee you it's
it's definitely going to be less than 30
of women in stem or something it's
changed a lot throughout the last like
10 to 15 years that's a guarantee but
before then it was mostly men in these
types of positions and majors and all
that because
women weren't really given an interest
into it they weren't really given a
like a pathway but now that they are
it's enjoyable yeah and it's great that
we're in it now but not everybody is no
but now they are they're not choosing
them
they're not choosing women generally
aren't choosing the stem fields
i feel like i know a lot of women in
stem but i can only speak from
statistically they're not choosing it
yeah it's just like the numbers don't
back that up so because if you if they
um they did a study where they took the
countries that have the most choice when
it comes to like jobs you know what i'm
saying like so you take like
more you know like middle eastern
countries where women have less choice
and you take more egalitarian countries
where women have more choice and the
more choice that women have like the the
more they choose jobs that have to do
with people and not things because women
like we value relationships yeah so
you'll see more women going into like
medicine yeah like midwifery and that's
what like this would be a midwife so
yeah social care and and realistically
though that's because that's our
strength you know we have a nurturing
kind of nature to us that men often
times cannot provide at the end of the
day so like i see nothing wrong with
women not stepping into stem more than
before
like it's okay i i do agree with you in
that sense that like hey man so then if
if you believe in like equal
or if feminists believe in like equal
um
opportunities right
you don't even equal opportunity doesn't
um equal
equal outcome
we talked about this briefly
i agreed
i agreed with that fully i'm the type of
person where it's like if you can't step
up to the plate and deliver
it's not for you point-blank period
like
and if you really want to continue
whatever field you're going into by all
means do so but you're gonna have to
work twice as hard you know and
especially if you're a woman you know
and in a male-dominated situation you
might be looked at a little bit more
crazy